[Musique]
les topinambours et les salsifis des
légumes méconnus sont à la fois
succulent et différente de ce que nous
consommons tous les jours c'est un
légume qui viennent d'amérique on a
longtemps cru que c'est un légume qui
venaient du québec
or ce légume qui vient des états unis
que les autochtones connaissait qu'ils
vont implanter ici et c'est champlain
qui va le faire découvrir en europe qui
sera le premier en 1605
au début on n'a pas le choix pour
vaincre la faim donc on adopte certains
aliments autochtone mais très rapidement
l'alimentation des colons français
deviennent résolument française donc le
topinambour vont perdre en popularité
s'étonner d'une tige dont le tubercule
porte aussi le nom de truffes du canada
prix artichauts de jérusalem
c'est que la plante lafleur ressemble à
celle du tournesol et en italie on
appelle ça girassol alors les églises
ont entendu duras à lyon du jazz ont tu
ressembles je ressens même alors il fait
ça l'artisan de jérusalem mais qui
achète ça c'est les épiceries ou les
restaurateurs
je vais directement les restaurants
notre connexion audio ces produits sont
cultivés en petits volumes
ils sont par le fait même plus difficile
à trouver ça fait des golfs loge un
galet plafond belle il faut que
quelqu'un qui gèle à brailler maillard
qu'est ce que vous allez me donner comme
conseils comment vous allez me dire
d'arrêter ses fruits comme les potable
même chose même chose de potable juste
il avait effectué c'est un de mes
légumes préférés pour le chef fehmi
benabed le topinambour a toujours eu sa
place en cuisine
au maroc on utilise beaucoup le
topinambour puis on l'appelle pas très
bien c'est comme ce qu'on sait ça
s'appelle si ma mère l'utilisent aussi
énormément dans les tajines les
techniques de cuisson utilisés font
varier sa texture cru il va être très
creux quand il va être
c'est gore jets d'eau contrairement à
une fois cuit par exemple au four rôti
alors il est comment peut en purée en
intérieur comme un peu une pomme de
terre sans itunes pommes de terre un
petit goût artichauts petit goût en même
temps un peu un peu l'étau s'est mis
benabed nous concocte une soupe dans
laquelle il intègre des lardons
pour ajouter une touche de folie elle
sera garni de ses fleurs en plus des
topinambours qu'ils sont cuits ils
utilisent une déclinaison de ce légume
cru et encensent
[Musique]
il nous a également préparé un dessert
deux binômes
c'est quoi la différence entre le
salsifis noir de sa cible le programme
différent j'ai juste lu le bligh reef
est plus délicate qu'il nettoie ses
quatre tours de la fin de la file bien
ils tâchent blair s'attachent les maires
le celle ci lui est une plante
appartenant à la famille des astéracées
comme le topinambour
il est peu cultivés au québec tous enfin
une zone donnée qu'on fait on met en
avant plus la convention de dépôt
pourquoi ça se vend pas mais on dit
qu'on ne sait pas sur la société belge
les belges achètent le noyage at paul
blanc qui mangent du salsifis au québec
c'est très rare on a essayé de
l'implanter au début du régime français
on sait que c'est du salsifis noir qu'on
a implanté ici surtout dans des jarres
des deux communautés religieuses mais
sans plus en réalité on devrait
l'appeler scorsonère plutôt que celle-ci
fille noire et il n'est disponible qu'à
l'automne dans une approche plus
locavore on recommence à l'utiliser dans
nos cuisines comme on utilise le panais
ou la carotte
c'est comme un peu le pas n'est ce sens
son petit côté peace on veut les
peluches et comme une carotte salle
oxydes très rapidement comme un peu une
pomme quand la chaire va devenir brune
parce qu'elle va oxydé on sort avec
l'orgueil fumée langue et de kamouraska
on prend le celles ci vont veulent la
voir en purée on veut l'avoir retirée on
va la voir aussi cru et voilà on
commence par quoi ça me bats je pense
qu'on va commencer par la soupe
cette soupe et soyeuse et la présence de
lardons révèle une petite explosion de
saveurs à chaque bouchée l'anguille
fumée accompagnée de celle ci fuit en
purée rôti et cru nous permet d'en
apprécier les différentes textures mais
qui aurait cru que le topinambour
pouvait être servis crème glacée c'est
de toute beauté comme sow qui des
experts presqu'une au règne c'est réussi
ah oui non vraiment avec le mariage de
sucre et l'eau bon ben vous allez
peut-être nous convaincre de s'attaquer
aux topinambours et celle ci merci
beaucoup ça me fait plaisir c'est à
doigts
[Musique]